hey what's up I'm Tony Hawk you're
watching wired video and I'm manually
right there on the screen oh hi if
you've been watching game life for a
while you know one thing I am not cool
but check this out Tony Hawk he is going
to teach me how to be awesome with this
thing is holding Tony what what is this
uh this is the skateboard controller for
a new game called ride ride yeah rock
rock tony hawk ride yeah this is a
departure from anything we've done in
the past and something I've wanted to do
for a long time but just felt like the
technology wasn't ready yet but it now
is the time and this thing's amazing
it's wireless it's got two
accelerometers got infrared sensors all
around it so it knows if your hands are
coming in if your feet are pushing by
and it mimics that right on the screen
and it stays right on the floor right
you guys are on the floor I'm do
anything too fancy to everything too
fancy I mean if you really want to get
tricky with it like a skateboard you can
but you don't need to know how to skate
at all basically you just stand on it
and if you're on one of the sort of
casual modes it will steer for you for
the most part of guide you into the the
certain obstacles and challenges and
then you just have to have the timing to
sort of kick it back or throw it into a
wheelie or flick it spin it you know any
any subtle movement will send the board
actually doing them of trick Tony talk
is cheap I'm in the presence of
greatness right now and I'd like to see
you get tricky with it all right let's
do it
to start you would want to take your
back foot and scrape it by the over this
sensor to go for the push so keep your
front foot perpendicular like you had it
yeah and then take your back foot there
you go that would be the push right and
then you want to set your back foot up
on the tail like so it's actually up
there you go so then when you're going
into the the manual or the wheelie you
just kind of lean it back rock it back
there and that's it you're doing a
manual right there